hi my name is Joel Klein I'm going to be
doing a talk called life coding a web
app in the Wolfram cloud it's going to
be what it sounds like we're going to be
writing a program from scratch and
exploring how to use the Wolfram cloud
to build a complete web application
I have a little bit of an unusual format
for this talk the live coding means that
instead of a talk with a bunch of slides
I'm going to be writing a program and
talking out loud my thought process in
the past I've given talks where I was
talking about you know programming for
the cloud the programmers environment
for the cloud and this is sort of in
that same vein but more hands-on
approach I've done this sort of thing
in-house inside the company five times
now and it's it's gone five different
ways every time we pick something new we
try it out and sometimes it's it's
pretty fun other times it kind of
derails and so it's just like real
coding the idea here is that we're
picking familiar types of web apps we're
trying to pick off something that
everybody's kind of familiar with and
there's many motivations for why we're
doing this my one of my main motivations
is just you know can I do kind of a
minimal Viable Product and with our
technology do I run into any problems do
I see you know once I put myself in the
driver's seat of the user this is how I
thought it was supposed to work but now
that I'm there I can see okay you know
either there's a bug here or this could
be a little bit better experience so
that's kind of my motivation as an
internal person but I also see it's
pretty useful as just an example so I'd
like to kind of develop a suite of these
examples if possible and make them
available in my path and we'll talk
there's a link at the end to a live web
page and I'll for the foreseeable future
anyway I'll be linking examples there I
linked some live examples that I didn't
have last week the links weren't there
the examples were so if you go back to
that you'll see some of the things we've
done
and I want to can i zoom this yeah yeah
that's going to be interesting once I
start coding but definitely for for this
I can so some of the types of web apps
were talking about the blog the online
store evite surveys and it's it's kind
of interesting once you get into this
mindset of kind of studying these as you
know a familiar thing what's at the core
of it is what I'm wondering what's the
data flow to this it's interesting to
see how some of these are actually very
similar to others the ones I've bolded
here are ones that I've I've attempted
in my in my internal talks and some of
those the ones that were successful have
demo links the ones that weren't so
successful don't have demo links last
night or yesterday afternoon and into
the night I tried doing the classified
ads I tried to read you Craigslist and
wasn't wasn't too bad
Craigslist has this interesting aspect
to it that you don't have to register as
a user to use it it kind of interacts
with your email to you know so that you
can go edit things you know you're you
get his email where you have a link to
delete things or go back to edit your
post so that's kind of interesting the
the demo there is not completely
functional got it to the point where you
can you know submit a new listing and
and it shows up in a listing but it
doesn't actually take you to the listing
yet so just want to set your
expectations a couple things apologies
in advance if I spend most of my time
looking down at the screen instead of up
at you and the other thing is we we may
not get to a fully functional web app of
any description by the end but you're
hopefully going to see kind of the
thought process and how we're getting
there I've you this more as a as a sport
you know like one of my favorite of
sports is baseball and just
you know you don't know if you're going
to be able to hit that blazing ball
coming by you or not sometimes you're
successful sometimes you're not so this
is more like a sport than like a play
where you have a can talk so our method
the the rough outline of what I'm going
to try to do I'm going to pick a topic
and for a long time when I was
anticipating this talk I was I was
little I was gonna try to do this as
pure as possible and I started realizing
that's not fair to the audience I was
going to come up here and say okay I
don't know what I'm gonna do
let's pick something and go completely
blind I'm not going to do that I've
thought a little bit about what I want
to do but I'm still following the same
process so the first thing is we're
going to talk about what are the
absolutely bare essential features that
we're trying to do if you don't focus on
that you're not going to get through
much in in in an hour or half an hour or
whatever I'm going to just go through so
and then we're going to go into the
model-view-controller view of building
any kind of interface and sometimes I'm
going to I think play a little fast and
loose with the terms here the model for
my purposes can be both just some data
that's in memory in Mathematica is very
nice prototyping environment so we can
you know say well this is what the data
is I haven't built the whole thing to
create the data yet but I can just you
know make some example data off the fly
but the model can also be how am i
representing that data how am i
persisting it and the more I've worked
on this the more I realize you know that
really is a big part of the problem
we're solving the view just the
presentation of how it looks and even
more important how we transition between
the different pages that we have and
then the controller just the the web
endpoints the cloud objects that that
are making the whole thing work one big
thing about the view that I want to and
a couple caveats before we get it really
get into this
I started out my first example I picked
was a blog and a blog is interesting
because the core of that content the
blog post formatting is really important
and I naturally picked a cloud notebook
as the the way that we would present
that and we would edit that because it
was already built for a lot of these
other things like the the Craigslist
formatting is still kind of important
but it's not as critical but I still had
this choice about how am I going to how
am I going to make this online and for
the time being I'm relying completely on
cloud notebooks actually I had thought
that I was going to do this with just
you know ryj tml and raw or or generated
HTML and one of the things you can do is
you can go you know surfing the web you
can find some template if you're not a
designer you can kind of custom it
customize that you can turn it into you
know the XML template in the language
you know put in template slots you can
iterate over sequences it works I've
done it but right now that's not as
productive as just using the user
interface elements the typesetting and
just the cloud notebook display features
there's a lot of trade-offs with that
because cloud notebooks were not built
to be the web so there's some things
that don't quite work I may also do
things a little bit differently as far
as data storage I'm completely just
using sort of expressions stored in
cloud objects and one of the problems
that bugs me as I do this all the time
is synchronization you know if you have
multiple people hitting your craigslist
site your Craigslist knockoff the
software that I'm building is
susceptible to well if two people kind
of put their requests in at the same
time you can get this interleaving
that's going to result in somebody's
data getting lost in the future I won't
promise one but in the future we will
have support for a synchronization on
cloud objects a way to do that that
exists right now is cloud expressions so
you might ask why might
using cloud expressions I'm not going to
try to justify that whole that whole
thing right now is an excellent way to
model this so I'm not downplaying I'm
just not doing it right now sort of
basically for simplicity of presentation
it's just much easier to say I'm getting
on pudding so let's get started to do
pick a web app okay and then implement
it okay so if we go back to our list of
types what I'm thinking about is a forum
just discussion threads so actually I do
want to mention some common tools
because I am following kind of a similar
thing all the time
I'm going to be using I'm going to start
by defining a root directory for the
application and everything is built off
of that so deploying the application is
you know a create directory inside that
directory is going to be a home page and
then other pages we build will will come
off of that I've got a couple of utility
functions that I'm finding really
important to already have predefined one
of them is just and I'm not a front-end
anything so there's probably better ways
to do this but basically I've defined a
function output cell that where I give
it some kind of a display expression
like a row or a column or something and
that gives me an output cell where
that's going to be typeset and I'm going
to use this for hyperlinks for lists and
all kinds of things and the other thing
that I found useful is the app header
cell where in a cloud notebook I can
make a docked cell that's always going
to appear at the top I can kind of give
you a consistent look and feel for all
of your pages you know the logo maybe a
menu or at least a backlink to the
homepage things like that and another
utility function for adding to a cloud
object that is a list of things that may
or may not exist when I start
the safe append and the output cell are
not there I can add these to the to the
the online resource but yeah I just I
literally threw these in a couple hours
ago
just sort of right after I handed in my
slide deck okay
so that's roughly where we're going so
let's get out of the the slide show
something keeps going fullscreen and I
don't know why okay okay so the the app
that I'd like to explore is is like I
said the forum I'm going to pick a cloud
object can you okay so this is the
critical point how well can you read
that we need to go 200 okay
so I am in I'm in the the public cloud
as we call it I'm logged in and I'm just
gonna have a directory WTC so what is
the what is our workflow so we're going
to have a home page on the home page we
want to have a list of posts we want to
have a way to create new posts so we're
going to have a create new discussion
thread sort of a link and then we'll
have a header that says we have a list
of threads and then we'll have you know
thread 1 kind of a title and so on and
those will link to thread pages what the
one question we have to ask ourselves is
identity of the users I think for a
forum you kind of want to know who
posting things so we're gonna make a
decision that you have to be logged in
and we'll have a we'll have a forum
title home is going to be the title and
then this is just my text kind of notes
of what the page look out a page layout
is like forum title and then we're gonna
have a switch that asks are you you know
is that is the user who requested this
logged in do we know who this user is if
they are not logged in we're gonna say
we're gonna have a link that says you
know log in to post or comment and if
they are already logged in will say you
know welcome you know user so that'll be
in our that will be in our header so we
have to do this page we have to handle
this we have to create a new discussion
thread and we need to be able to list
these things yeah this is very different
when you're when you can't look as hat
as much as as on a larger screen let's
see I defined a route I'm going to so I
have a we have a function deploy app and
all of my functions I've decided makes
sense to take as an argument the root of
the of the whole app and this gives us
flexibility to sort of take this as a
cookie cutter and create in our case
create a new forum one simplifying
assumption we're making here is that you
know you might have a forum site where
it has different categories I'm not
going to do categories basically this
forum is the category if that makes
sense so deploy deploy app is going to
be some things it's going to be we're
gonna create the directory for the
application and I'm quieting that
because create directory complains if it
already exists which is not something
that I'm a huge fan of but that's how it
works
and again it's our cloud objects this is
going to create the cloud object we're
going to redeploy the the homepage and
there is a and I'm going to return that
at the end of deploy app so finally I'm
join is overloaded to work with cloud
objects and finally I'm join is the way
that I construct cloud objects that are
you know basically take this cloud
object and add stuff to the end of it
and this is such a common idiom that
this this is in my usual bag of tricks
now the the app link
it's just saving a few characters but
it's it sort of makes it readable so
deploy home and I want to get this up as
soon as possible so we can kind of see a
coming soon page so deploy home is like
all the functions taking the route cloud
object it is going to cloud deploy and
for right now I'm gonna have it say
coming soon say it again
I'm going to have this be a delayed and
it's going to be the type cloud CDF
we're deploying to the app home cloud
object and it's going to be public okay
so we'll see sorry
yes I do so where's our mistake
your rights thank you mm-hmm I'm gonna
try okay so now we're gonna see what we
get here yes so one of the things that's
coming in 11 3 is cloud object name
format where the default for named cloud
objects is that in this user spec slot
here it's going to use your user URL
base which is by default it's kind of
the left hand side of your wolfram ID
email address for me that's Jeff Klein
the default right now is to use the full
user UUID which is a the nice thing
about that is it's a stable ID it can
never change you can't change it but
it's not very readable and in my case I
want to publish this so I want a nicer a
nicer name so we're often you know often
going in in the sense that we've got
some vapor where now I'm going to save
this just because that's my habit and
I'm going to make a tiny little window
to redeploy
as we work on that
so the homepage we really really wanted
this to be a notebook I'm going to keep
it like that and I'm going to add so a
cell at Excel that says that and we're
going to have a here is where I'm going
to I'm going to make use of this app
header cell function that I defined
before so it takes the route cloud
object a title and content so root
technology conference forum it's too
long and some some content cells so I'm
just going to put something there I am
needing to close the notebook expression
so there we go
we now have the docked cell and we have
a space to put some other stuff and what
did we say we said we need to login to
poster comment and start a new
discussion and the posts lists so this
part I'm going to put my out pet output
cell a hyperlink start a new discussion
thread and I have an app linked to a
cloud object called create or it will be
and we're going to have a know what am i
doing
we're going to have a cell that's going
to say posts and it's the subsection and
we're going to have I'm going to join in
this is a placeholder function too
to convert a post piece of post
information to a cell
I'm going to map it over the empty list
for now because we don't have any posts
so that's a that's a to do and I'm going
to redeploy
so the start a new discussion thread
will have to create that we also want
people to log in and in order to start a
new discussion thread we want people
logged in anyway so I'm going to modify
this this part this is in that docked
cell so we're going to check to see if
the requester is none that means there
unauthenticated they need to log in so
we're going to put a link their login to
post or comment and we need a plink
takes root and if they are logged in
we're going to have a row that welcomes
them
and I would like to welcome using like a
full name one of the things that I've
I've thought about this whole project is
that I'm really trying to make a minimal
Viable Product I want to like during
like basically out of you know an hour
or choose worth of work have something
that is the bare-bones and what happens
once you have that bare-bones program
that takes you know maybe I don't know
that much doesn't take that much code
what tends to happen as you look at it
you start to see like well you know what
I'd really like to have users register I
don't want them just logging in I want
them to make a profile and what's nice
is that you know sort of for educational
reasons or just for learning the system
if you look at sort of this example
minimal you know implementation you can
kind of it kind of just begs you like
don't you want to add this feature to
create a profile and so I think it's
motivating for people to say like well
it doesn't already have this feature I
can add it and I can edit it in some way
that I envision or that I want to
customize so I'm not putting that in
there I'd like to have like a full name
here I'm going to put their email
address let's see did I what did I not
close off so I need to close off the if
and I'm gonna redeploy that and I kind
of needed a spacer this this was too
close so this part right here I'm just
going to literally add you know a few
spaces
so here we can see I'm logged in mm-hmm
it's it's welcoming me if you have a
laptop if somebody wants to try visiting
this address objects jf Kline capital
WTC slash home and you're not logged
into the cloud just let me know if it if
it shows you as expected that it's not
logged in now we need to we need to
build this this logged in page or I
called a login page my thought there is
I want a hyperlink the user to a page
and I want that page to require that
they login the way to do that is
actually with permissions
so the login page is going to have C
deploy login page root cloud object this
is going to be a cloud deploy of let's
just say Adelaide again and gonna do a
column ok minimal Viable Product
I could do a link here but I'm actually
going to just say you know press the
back button
so I don't really need that column but
that's that's fine so we need an uplink
what did we call it law log in capital L
capital I and the permissions that we're
going to use this is the key part are
authenticated goes to read actually in
this case execute since it's a it's a
delay this could be static it doesn't
have to be delayed delayed is when you
want to delayed means do a calculation a
computation so that's deploy login page
I'm going to check the app link to see
that we linked it so capital L capital I
log in and after we deploy after we
create the directory we're going to
deploy the login page as well and make
that part of part of deploying the app
I'm not going to check that right now
we're gonna move on cool it works the
authenticated just means that you know
if you're an authenticated user you need
permission and that the logic here is
that when you visit a page if you don't
already have permissions according to
whatever rules a permission system gives
you it makes you login no matter what
once you login then you have the
permissions and you it lets you see that
okay we need to we need to do a couple
of things we need to create the the
model for the posts and we need to
create a way to to add to them the
example I did yesterday with their
classified ads the approach was you know
one of the concerns that you always have
when you're designing one of these
things is scalability and one of the
things that I ended up deciding to do
with like a classified ad that seems to
make sense here is divide things by days
so if today somebody posts something
we're going to write it to a collection
for today's posts things that were
created on this date and then when we
list things we can you know list we can
it gives us some flexibility for sort of
like I'm going to show the unlimited
number of days so anyway that's that's
the thought but we need that list so
there's going to be a data directory for
cloud objects that are just sort of the
data behind this and that is an app link
to make it lowercase data and when we
deploy the app we want that data
directory to exist
so this is this is the this is one of
the model parts so model for posts so we
want to have in the data directory we
want to have a list of dates in a dates
dot M this is just going to be for
example a list of strings sort of like
year-month-day format
so content like that and then the
discussion we want to think about how we
want to represent the the discussion
thread itself so the the discussion
thread the thread itself we have some
metadata like the user that created it
the title and sort of their initial post
so thread thread information so we have
the date created the user who created a
title the initial post content that sort
of sounds like it's not any different
from the rest of the post content so we
might store that in a separate place we
might have these things in an
association and then the initial post
content can just be stored along with
follow-ups what about a thread a thread
post is sort of the same thing so you
can
you're talking about the the safe put ah
these are just stars as it just
asterisks escape bu escape is the bullet
symbol yeah so with a thread post looks
very similar it's going to have D
created user who created it and the
content in that case if we if we make so
say list of say list of posts which
includes the initial one
so what I'm imagining is a directory
data threads and then for a particular
yeah for a particular date we need a
list of threads so they'll actually be
I can imagine that a data / datum would
give you lists the threads for that date
under the under the threads then we have
these don't have to be partitioned by
date but they can be
yeah I found that this is this is where
this model design is where I often kind
of go back and forth between some
different representations and the more
the more I look at it the more I think
that there's a that there's a regular
way of approaching this and what I'm
really thinking about is you know what
is that kind of uniform way to approach
it
I think in the in the interest of time
we're going to go with just a flat
representation of of the threads we're
not going to go by dates so that would
be
that would be more like a threads damn
where we would have some IDs so an ID
for number one an ID for number two and
then so let's let's try to do that let's
say let's say that there's there's a
thread data object which is an app link
Appling of the data with threads down
and then thread data is going to fetch
that
so if we have a so let's say app home of
our roots we want to check that and
AppData of root is that then the thread
data object is this threads down and it
doesn't have anything in it right now
there's nothing in there so I think what
we're going to do is
is sort of a safe version of this a safe
but not very synchronized version
so there's no thread data right now and
if we want to create a new thread that
means two things it means adding to this
list and it means creating the thread
the thread information so the data
threads dem we're gonna have these IDs
instead of a date it's just going to be
a thread ID and then the thread itself
is going to have posts so there's going
to be a thread dem for many information
about the thread which includes I think
the thread posts make sense to separate
out so the thread dem would include
things like the date created the user
created it in the title the thread posts
would be the list of post IDs
and then a post directory would have
post IDM files that contain the rest of
it
so what did we have we had
I'm going to move this this code for the
thread model down by our notes for the
thread
so we want to write a function that's
going to create a new thread what does
that involve
it's going to involve we're going to
have a data a data Association and the
data will have
created field creating user and a title
it will also have an ID that will be
some random ID or maybe we will assign
that so they could they create thread
once we get this function we can create
a form that's going to call this
function which is going to add it to our
model we're going to create a random
integer some ID that's in a somewhat
compact form we're going to have a cloud
object for it
one of the last things we're going to do
in this is append so the SAF append
function that I added what we want is we
want to add to the threads dot M or the
the thread posts damn I guess we want to
add the ID so we need
we need a thread posts object
so safe upend will append to that thread
posts object it will append the data and
we're going to append to this data an ID
field so this data that we're getting in
we're going to add another field with
this ID we're actually going to say that
the this is a rule so I'm changing the
model there the the model is going to
have no we said that that no we said the
threads dot M is going to be the list of
ID's that's right so we're actually
pending to thread data object just the
ID okay
so that populates threads dot em with
this we need this threads directory
created
so we're going to add that to the deploy
home
I call it just threads Durer
so this directory has now been created
we added some code to append to that
list we need to create the ID directory
so thread data directory a root and a
thread ID string is an app link of the
read data and the thread ID well double
check that so past root here and just a
made-up ID we just want to check what
the cloud object is gonna look like that
is not right what's up
so that thing is empty thread data
yeah threads doer thank you
I think since we're getting close to the
end of the time I'm gonna try to wrap up
a thought here and and take a couple of
questions so WC data threads and then
the ID so that that looks right
threads Dirar so part of this would be
creating the directory for the thread
data Durr and the ID so that gives us
that gives us this level and then we
would be creating the thread M from this
data so the two do's here are create in
the ID dated er the threads dot M with
data and then populate the thread post
stem with a list of one thing the
initial post once we get that then we
would have we would have created enough
of the model that we could at least call
from the command line a function or
command line that the inside the
language we could call a function to
populate that data and then we could
work on displaying the data under the
post lists we would be iterating from
that okay that's where I'm gonna go
don't know where I drank this on the on
the success list it did actually turn
out to be more involved than than I
thought
but that's what I have so questions
with all of these I'm trying to go back
to them as I have time and round them
out yeah yeah yeah so the idea that what
at what I envision I think what I what I
deal is that I published you know all
those functions so you kind of have a
package and it's it's what I like is you
know I've used WordPress from time to
time and that's that's a neat language
or needs a neat environment if you know
it's a certain kind of it does a certain
thing you know it's it's obviously very
feature-rich so I'm sort of imagining it
a bit like WordPress that one of the
differences being that this is not only
the software that runs on the back end
but it's also a deployment so from our
desktop we can be pushing this up to
Wolfram cloud in various spots so it
sort of takes takes care of the hosting
part as well as the engine yeah Bob what
is it it is good for some things
it's definitely pros and cons right now
I think it's it's one thing that you'll
notice if you try some of my demos is
that links always open in a new tab
which is not ideal that's probably the
number one glaring like what's going on
thing but there's a lot of there's a lot
of good things from it we're did another
question
on this page okay okay that's
interesting I can look into that yeah
other than iframe right now no yeah so I
think that's my time I'll be happy to
take questions afterwards but
[Applause]